[Musique]
bonjour à tous vous avez tous remarqué
ça y est c'est la réouverture des
cinémas au grenier à sel nous avons
décidé de rouvrir le mardi 30 juin à
20h45
pour cela nous vous avons concocté un
petit programme spécial nous avons une
avant-première donc le 30 juin à 20h45
il s'agit du film voir le jour un film
de marion laine avec sandrine bonnaire
et aure atika c'est un film qui se passe
dans le milieu médical avec
une des infirmières
aux maternités et donc avec tous les
sujets qu'on a pu voir ces derniers
temps ça tombe à point nommé
ça va nous donner du grain à moudre pour
notre réflexion et c'est super donc ce
sera mardi 30 juin à 20h45
il a survécu mais l'autre peint tu avais
pas lu son dossier jean marie claude tu
sais comment c'est con mais je sais
c'est lui qui te garde oui série louis
la raison de porter plainte parce qu'il
y en a marre de ces conditions sont pour
l'instant c'est moi qui leur sert de
bouc émissaire on savait depuis quand tu
travailles tu as l'habitude non non je
m'habitue pas en ce qui concerne les
conditions sanitaires maintenant le port
du masque est obligatoire dans les halls
et dans les circulations est soit de
circulation pour aller aux toilettes
pour vous déplacer il faut un masque
c'est obligatoire et nous n'en avons pas
nous ne fournissons pas ton pensez avoir
le vôtre sinon vous ne pourrez pas
rentrer il faudra laisser un fauteuil m
autour de vous à droite et à gauche
que vous soyez vous êtes en famille ce
sera à gauche et à droite de votre
famille voilà donc nous vous donnons
rendez-vous mardi 30 juin pour leur
grande réouverture de ces volcans dix
ans elle a bientôt
[Musique]